foreign
[Music]
hey guys in this video I'm going to
share with you the top 10 movies of all
time that had a huge impact on my life
you know movies come and go right but
then there are some that just man
they're just in a whole new other level
and they they change the way you think
about things about life that is just the
power of Storytelling
let's start with the first one
foreign
Braveheart man if you have not watched
this you have no idea what you're
missing one of the best movies ever
and more men need to watch this movie to
show them the importance of what it
means to have freedom because in the
world we live in today there are those
who want to take away our freedom
Braveheart is an amazing historical War
drama film with Mel Gibson as the lead
actor playing William Wallace he led the
Scots in the first war against England
for Scottish independence
the phone came out back in 1995 and even
to this date there is nothing like it
make some time and watch it
hacksaw rich
wow
when I watched this movie it just
inspired me encouraged me to keep on
fighting for truth to stand strong for
what I believe in the lead actor is
Andrew Garfield and he did an amazing
job here he played Desmond Doss who in
World War II said he will not carry a
weapon because of his fate
the Army laughed at him and actually
bullied him until they saw his bravery
and how he saved many lives in the worst
conditions then they actually followed
him
this is based on a true story and
directed by no other than Mel Gibson
Saving Private Ryan man what a great
movie A lot of the things that happened
in this movie are inspired by true
events and is directed by Stephen
Spielberg
make some time get the popcorn watch it
great actors like Matt Damon and Tom
Hanks really bring this movie to life
you know many men especially young men
who don't have any life experience yet
they stir up conflict easily and talk
about war while having no idea the pain
and suffering real war causes this film
focuses on the Battle of Normandy during
World War II it follows Tom Hanks and
his crew searching for James Ryan which
is played by Matt Damon they search for
him because all his three brothers died
and his mother would have received all
these letters informing her that all her
sons died all at once it would have been
devastating for her if her last
remaining son Ryan also died so the Army
decided to bring him home before he
diesel
this movie shows you what war is really
like
I mean
make some time watch it
foreign
oh man
what an amazing movie I will watch this
over and over and over one of the best
actors Tom Hanks he plays in this it's a
survival story directed by Robert
zamikis Tom Hanks is plane crash and he
gets stranded on an uninhibited island
in the South Pacific and he tries to
survive and finds his way back to
civilization
now I can go on and I can tell you what
happened you know but I'm not gonna
spoil the movie for you I can't do that
not with this movie so go and watch it
yourself
foreign
man what a movie they don't make movies
like this anymore movies of good strong
men who have honor
good morals and values
today they don't want men to be like
that anymore looking at what they kind
of weave into entertainment man it is
disgusting men without values and morals
men who are spineless weak and I want
them to be more like women
that's who they think real men should be
like today this is why I love Gladiators
so much it is a film directed by Ridley
Scott starring Russell Crowe playing as
the Roman General Maximus Decimus
Meridius who was betrayed by Commodus
the son of Emperor Marcus Aurelius who
killed his family and Maximus sold into
slavery
Maximus became a gladiator fighting and
Rising through the ranks to avenge his
family
this is a must watch for every man in
this world
The Passion of Christ
really good movie to watch you might not
be a Christian but you can still go and
watch it because it is historically
accurate so it's very interesting and
very realistic we know that Jesus
existed that he was real because of what
the Bible says other religious books but
also non-Christian or religious books it
was directed by Mel Gibson and Jim
Caviezel played the role of Jesus the
film shows us the final 12 hours leading
up to the crucifixion of Jesus Christ
and it finishes at his resurrection this
is the most accurate film I have ever
seen showing how Jesus really suffered
during the crucifixion this movie will
change the way you think about Jesus
forever
Forest Gump if you've never seen this
you need to go and watch this one of my
favorite movies ever and when you watch
it
you'll understand why it is a comedy
drama directed by Robert zemikis with
amazing life lessons that every man
needs to learn it follows the life story
of Forest Gump played by Tom Hanks who
is a super kind-hearted man of Alabama
but he's a little slow and different in
the way he thinks about things you know
I actually went to eat at Bubba Gump
Shrimp in the U.S just because of this
movie now I can't share too much of it
because I don't want to spoil this movie
for you let's move on
the case for Christ man I love true
stories this is based on a true story it
is about this investigative journalist
called Lee Strobel who worked at the
Chicago Tribune he's an atheist who
fights against his wife because of her
Newfound faith in God so he decided he's
going to disprove God by disproving
Jesus Christ and proving that what the
Bible says about him is false so he sets
out and investigates everything travels
to different countries to physically
look at the evidence and he does it in
the same way he would take on any other
investigation and finally all the
evidence points to I'm not going to tell
you go and watch the movie
The Pursuit of Happiness oh man Will
Smith gave one of his best performances
in this movie with his real son
wow what a movie it's based on a true
story I guess you know that I like true
stories by now Will Smith plays the role
of Chris Gardner who went from being
homeless needing to take care of himself
and his son to being a successful
businessman through a hard work and
determination this is a must watch for
all you lazy guys out there who never
want to go to work you always have
excuses
I'm not joking go and watch the movie
Rocky man when this came out everybody
watched it every man in this world needs
to go and see this movie because it's a
story about hard work dedication
self-discipline and consistency in
whatever you do all of which are
necessary to achieve success in this
life Sylvester Stallone wrote it and
played as the main actor for Rocky
Balboa who is an underdog uneducated
small-time boxer who through a hard work
discipline and determination becomes the
heavyweight champion now this movie was
actually showing Sylvester Stallone's
life real life because apart from the
movie in real life he was just an
unknown actor in Hollywood broke trying
to make it through hard work and
determination he was going so bad he
even had to go sell his dog because he
could not feed him anymore then he was
inspired by a boxing fight between
Muhammad Ali and Chuck Whitner and it
enabled him to write the script of Rocky
in just three days he brought the script
to the producers they looked at it they
loved it but they didn't love him
they offered him I think it was 360
000 dollars and he could have been like
yeah I needed the money let's take it
and go no
he stood strong he wanted to play in the
movie and he said no so
after a while they agreed and he played
in a movie and that's it
[Applause]
all right guys you watched this video
all the way to the end so here is the
bonus movie oh let me give you two the
first one unbroken what a amazing
inspiring movie that'll teach you to
stand strong for what you believe in and
not to be broken easily by anything or
anyone this movie is about Louis
Zamperini the American Olympian who was
caught by the Japanese Army in World War
II did I mention it based on a true
story well it is they tried to break him
to break his Spirit but they couldn't it
is a movie about resilience and one that
every man should watch
now I can't say any more than that and
it was directed and produced by you're
not going to believe this wait for it
Angelina Jolie and the actor is Jack
O'Connell now the last movie on my list
I still believe it's a true story based
on songwriter and singer Jeremy Camp and
his first wife Melissa who was diagnosed
with ovarian cancer
wow what an amazing movie that will show
you what it truly means to fully
surrender to God which is the best thing
we can do in this world to truly have
peace and purpose in this short
temporary world with all the terrible
stuff in it
now these are all the movies that every
man should watch and if you want to be a
better man a more successful man then
watch these videos here and I'll see you
there and always remember life is short
so don't waste yours cheers guys